friends and family of the release
prisoners gathered at Washington's
Dulles Airport to greet them both they
and those who landed in the U.S
expressed their surprise of what had
happened
we were obviously not told that we were
going to be freed we realized that when
they gave us our clothes at night and
took us to another cell they took us in
some buses without knowing where we were
going
among the prisoners those who led the
2018 protests against the government and
those with connections to ngos that
received U.S funding accused of
attempting to overthrow president Daniel
Ortega the opposition and the U.S have
maintained that these were civil society
figures attempting Democratic change
Through The Ballot Box following their
release Ortega said there had been no
deal with the U.S when they came to ask
what our interest was we said none let
them take them that's all it was not
about negotiating we are not asking for
sanctions to be lifted we are not asking
for anything in return it is a matter of
Honor dignity patriotism and for them to
take their mercenaries away
the U.S state Department also said this
was a unilateral decision where the
Nicaraguan government however added it
was also the product of concerted
American diplomacy and that the channels
of communication were open between the
two countries this action opens the door
to discussion of other matters of mutual
concern
the United States remains committed to a
dialogue with the government at
Nicaragua on these and other matters and
will continue to support the Nicaraguan
battle it's not clear yet where this
daytone may lead though members of the
Nicaraguan government and Ortega and his
family are under sanctioned by the US
government Shia britansi Al Jazeera
Washington